انيسه اكثر تعاطفا من الرجال ربما هو
بديهي بالنسبه لنا بحكم الخبره الحياتيه
لكن تم تاكيد هذه الان على اساس علمي
دراسه جديده اجراها علماء من جامعه
كيمبردج حللوا فيها بيانات اكثر من
300,000 مشارك من الرجال والنساء في 57
دوله الدراسه تهدفه للبحث فيما يعرف
بالتعاطف المعرفي وهو القدره على التخيل
ما يفكر فيه او يشعر به شخص اخر ووضع نفسك
مكان الاخرين لفهم ما يمرون به
سجلت النساء درجات اكثر من الرجال في
اختبار العيون الذي يقيس التعاطف المعركه
حيث يطلب من المشاركين النظر الى صوره شخص
ثم اختيار كلمه تصف ما يفكر فيه هذا الشخص
او يشعر به لمجرد النظر الى المنطقه
المحيطه بعيونهم باختصار تفوقت النساء من
جميع الاعمار في درجه التعاطف المعرفه في
36 دوله وتعادلنا مع الرجال في الدول
المتبقيه
[موسيقى]
اكيد الرجل
احساس اكثر لما حار من نوع رجل حساسي الى
درجه يعني ما يتوقعها اي انسان اكثر من
المراه بالنسبه
لك اختلاف ما بين المراه والرجل بهذا
الموضوع على اعتبار ان المراه طبيعه
ملامحها وتقاسيم الوجه هي تظهر اكثر
مصداقيه من الرجل بالتحديد لغه العيون
واذا تلاحظ سيكولوجيه العينيه تكشف ما
بداخل الناس المشاعر تكون عند الرجال وعند
النساء بعض الاحيان الرجل يشعر ان هو
مشاعره اكثر اتجاه المراه والمراه بعد
تكون هي الثقه مشاعر الرجل من خلال
احاسيسه ومشاعرها اتجاهها الشخص الموجود
يمها
[موسيقى]
الدراسه تقول ان النساء اكثر ذكاء عاطفيا
من حيث المشاعر من الرجال من الناحيه
العلميه الى اي مدى هذه الرساله هذه
الدراسه عفوا يمكن ان تكون دقيقه دقيقه
من الاحساس او اللي نحن بنقدر بنسميه
المراه كيف تقدر تكشف بالعين اول شيء
المراه تتفوق على الرجل في معرفه الالوان
في بعض الاحيان توصل الى ثلاثه اضعاف احنا
كرجال مثلا عندنا ثلاث الوان هو ثلاثه
الوان مهمين اللي هو اللون الاحمر والاخضر
والازرق اللون الاحمر في الاخر مع الرجل
هو يتميز فقط بثلاث درجات مع المراه بيوصل
الى طلب 12 الى 13 نوع وده رجل مختلف هذا
واحد اثنين في موضوع الاحساس بالطرف الاخر
نعم كهرمون كثر تركيبه كجسد امراه عمي هي
تشعر بالمشاعر اكثر من الشخص او الرجل هل
المراه اكثر قدره على قراءه لغه الجسد من
الرجل
ممكن ممكن نقول دعفان ونصف
[موسيقى]